the mood is changing the tone shifting
restrictions will be lifted next week
but the cold reality of cavite remains
july the 19th was meant to be
a moment of celebration instead we're
bracing
for danger i cannot say this powerfully
or
emphatically enough
this pandemic is not over
this disease coronavirus continues to
carry risks for you
and your family we will stick to our
plan to lift legal restrictions
and to lift social distancing but we
expect and recommend that people
wear a face covering in crowded and
enclosed
spaces where you come into contact with
those you don't normally meet
such as on public transport a major
change of
emphasis and not just on masks the pm
asking businesses to bring back workers
more slowly
and big venues to check our covered
status
and as a matter of social responsibility
we're urging nightclubs
and other venues with large crowds to
make use of the nhs covid pass
as the rules lift scientists too urge
him personal responsibility
there is going to be what's called an
exit wave there will be a wave
associated with that
and that the slower we take it the fewer
the people
will have coveted the smaller the peak
will be
and the smaller the number of people who
go into hospital and die
so going very slowly through this step
is really essential what was billed as
freedom day now with conditions attached
the prime minister trying to inject a
heavy
dose of caution into this final
unlocking as one number 10 insider put
it to me
there's no mission accomplished moment
when it comes to covid
instead we're moving into a new six
months phase where we have to try
to learn to live with it opening up even
as transmission and hospitalization
rates soar
but it comes with obvious risk and the
prime minister can't guarantee that he
won't have to go back
into reverse the labour leader thinks
the pm is steering us poorly through
this pandemic
i feel very strong at the moment that
the government wants to put
the country in a car without a seat belt
to get as quickly as possible to the end
of the
road map we need a safer way but this is
i'm afraid still reckless
and in oxford where cases are soaring
some are skeptical people will do the
right thing
you only have to look at events like the
football final last night to see
responsibility is not really going to be
taken very seriously
the problem is the younger ones the
catch in it
they're not as ill as older ones
but the dumb good spreaders we've been
the vulnerable
ones now the young people because we're
not fully vaccinated yet
so just like we had to stay at home and
wear a mask for
uh the older generations and the more
vulnerable people who had to wear masks
we would appreciate the same being done
for us
from next week it will be left to each
of us to manage this pandemic
but replacing clear rules with
recommendations is a risky way to
navigate this third wave
the country bracing for a bumpy summer
beth rigby sky news